la siguiente función es continua
diferenciable en x 3 y aquí nos dan una
función definida por partes y algunas
opciones que tenemos que escoger
continua pero no diferenciables
diferenciable pero no continua ambas
continua y diferenciable o ninguna ni
continua ni diferenciable ahora de todas
estas opciones ya podemos tachar una
porque para que una función sea
diferenciable tiene que ser continua
entonces desde ahorita ya podemos decir
que esta opción no puede suceder y ahora
pensemos en la continuidad de esta
función pensemos si la función es
continua para empezar como acabamos de
decir si una función no es continua no
es diferenciable pero vamos a empezar
viendo si esta función es continua
así es que pensemos un poquito al
respecto
efe sea continua en 3
efe de 3 tiene que ser igual al límite
cuando x tiende a 3 d efe de x ahora
cuánto es
efe de 3 bueno pues efe de 3 está
definido en este caso cuando x es igual
a 3 fx es 6 x menos nueve o sea 6 por 3
18 menos 99
así es que f de 3 es 9 entonces el
límite cuando x tiende a 3 de fx tiene
que ser igual a 9 para que la función
sea continua empecemos pensando en el
límite cuando x tiende a 3 por la
izquierda el límite cuando x tiende a 3
por la izquierda
de x si x tiende a 3 por la izquierda
estamos tomando valores de x menores que
3 y estos caen en este caso y en este
caso
fx es igual a x al cuadrado entonces
tenemos aquí x al cuadrado fx y esto
está definido y es continuo en todos los
reales entonces podemos simplemente
sustituir el 3 aquí y nos queda igual a
9 pero ahora cuál es el límite cuando x
tiende a 3 por la derecha límite cuando
x tiende a 3 por la derecha de f de x
bueno pues cuando x tiende a 3 por la
derecha que estamos tomando valores de x
mayores a 3 y entonces caemos en este
caso o sea que fx es igual a 6 x menos 9
x menos 9 y sucede lo mismo por aquí 6 x
9 está definida y es continua para todos
los números reales entonces podemos aquí
simplemente sustituir al 3 y nos queda
18 menos 9 que es
9 así es que tanto el límite por la
izquierda como el límite por la derecha
de la función f x son iguales a 9 y 9 es
el valor de la función en 3 por lo que
podemos decir que f es continua en x
igual a 3
efe definitivamente es continua así es
que ya podemos tachar esta opción porque
si es una función continua y ahora nos
quedan estas dos opciones por lo que
tenemos que pensar en la diferencia
habilidad ahora para que una función sea
diferenciable diferenciable tiene que
existir el límite cuando x tiende a 3 de
fx menos f de 3 / x menos 3
así es que veamos si podemos encontrar
este límite para empezar ya sabemos
cuánto es
efe de 3 sabemos que es igual a 9 y
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es encontrar
el límite por la izquierda y el límite
por la derecha y si ambos límites
coinciden entonces esa cosa a la que
coinciden
es el límite cuando x tiende a 3
empecemos por el límite cuando x tiende
a 3 por la izquierda estamos dividiendo
entre x menos 3 y en el numerador
tenemos
efe de x menos 9 pero ahora como estamos
aproximando a 3 por la izquierda todos
los valores de x son menores que 3 y por
lo tanto fx para esos valores es x al
cuadrado si es que por acá tenemos x al
cuadrado menos 90 x al cuadrado menos 9
es una diferencia de cuadrados por lo
que lo podemos reescribir de esta forma
como x + 3
x menos 3 y ahora estos dos se cancelan
siempre y cuando x no sea igual a 3 pero
como estamos aproximando a x por la
izquierda x nunca va a ser igual a 3 en
este límite así es que si los podemos
cancelar y nos queda simplemente x + 3 0
x 3 es continua para todos los números
reales entonces aquí simplemente podemos
sustituir al 3 y esto nos queda igual a
6 bueno ahora tenemos que encontrar el
límite cuando x tiende a 3 por la
derecha y entonces en el denominador
tenemos x menos 3 y en el numerador efe
de x menos 9 pero como estamos
aproximando a 3 por la derecha estamos
en este caso y fx es 6 x menos 9
6 x menos 9 sf y nos falta restar menos
9 que es efe de 3 porque tenemos fx
- efe de 3 entonces aquí tenemos 6x
menos 18 menos 18 pero esto es igual a 6
por x 3 y conforme nos aproximamos a 3
por la derecha esto es igual a 6 así es
que como estos dos límites son iguales
si existe este límite y es igual a 6
o sea que si existe la derivada de la
función f en 3 y su valor es 6 el límite
cuando x tiende a 3 de todo esto es
igual a 6 porque el límite de esto
cuando x tiende a 3 por la izquierda y
cuando tiende por la derecha son iguales
a 6 lo que esto nos dice es que f
ambas continua y diferenciable